okay so we got a hundred and twenty
peasants versus one Rocky Balboa let's
see what happens I don't know how I
think you're gonna [ __ ] you didn't even
get to one I think I have an erection a
dick I have a tumor I think I have
cancer
I think I have a pet name oh my god
we're gonna come from where to go where
the [ __ ] did the video go I'm a name and
I'm not Paco they're gonna hug it out
they're peaceful Bunch
[Music]
you're gonna that well that's one down
range does nothing when they hump you
from either side point oh my god you're
angry visited Oh give me big kids not
about the other drawer
oh no it is seitan well goodbye then
like oh goodness gracious Oh
[Music]
wonderful awesome they did they're so
happy oh wow oh god my users need
pumping I'm pumping as hard as I can
you're gonna get both cannons now no no
please
Oh God ah yep that's what you deserve
fly them up in here and get those bear
traps all go get the ones that are over
to the left you got it um on yeah I
remember like oops I remember like
exploring the entirety of the mapping
and I couldn't really find this go back
how good pause my bad they weren't up
there were they oh you sack of [ __ ]
actually believed you but oh my god oh
my oh no they're just hoping that dead
one oh I got it oh good lord
is that a barbarian I think I swallowed
my pen name I'm sorry I'm this is not
funny
you're not gonna [ __ ] you're not gonna
trick me
I'm gonna trick me I'm the only one that
tricked me trick dude gasps looks
promising you like this dramatic music
playing as we watch this guy BAP is dick
around back and forth
oh so sensually oh well be bad now hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to the rake multiplayer we
got funny village of it okay I don't
yeah it was wrong what
while this one is I don't know you're
going to the camera see yeah you like
that
what how about a little bat on the tip
of your giant nose Oh
float like a butterfly just like a mean
what's it like to be gay
what's it like to be a girl
[Music]
[Laughter]
after whoever's on the roof that's lazy
or not at all
little boats you think we can get laid
don't know get do glows I want to kill
them oh wow thanks for watching all of
the videos in this compilation are
available in the description so check
them out and if you'd like to see more
in the future please leave a like to let
me know if you enjoyed this video and
you'd like to see more in a daily basis
please subscribe today or if you're
already subscribed share this video with
a friend thanks again for watching and
I'll see you in the next video bye bye